Andy Rubin, head of
Google's Android team until 2013
famously defined Android's
openness with this Tweet,
offering the instructions for
downloading and building
the Android source code.
As app developers,
it's handy to be able to peak
behind the curtains and see
how the framework actually works.
And it's an excellent way
to find answers
to tricky Stack Overflow questions.
But the Android Open Source Project,
or AOSP as its commonly known,
is much more than that.
The source code is available
under the Apache 2 license,
so anyone can take it
and do anything they want with it,
including modifying it
and redistributing it.
And they have.
Android has always had
a passionate community of modders,
from Steve Kondik
and the Cyanogen community
to XDA and many others
who have been distributing
modified images of Android
for phone owners
brave enough to try them.
Even big companies like Amazon
have taken the Android source code
and modified it for use
in their own line of products.
That openness extends
to the apps themselves.
The AOSP includes key mobile apps
like the dialer, app launcher,
calendar, and email.
And Google offers its
own versions of each as well.
In the early days those native apps
were tightly bound
to the framework and could only
get updated along with the platform.
Which admittedly in the early days
seemed like every few weeks.
But as the time between
platform releases grew,
so did the efforts
to unbundle those apps,
allowing them to be updated
through Google Play.
That was great news for users,
but it had an even better side effect
for us developers.
Because apps like Gmail and Maps
depend on a number
of proprietary Google APIs,
Google released Google Play Services.
Also code named after food
to support the Google apps,
while also giving us developers
Google specific APIs,
like Maps, Wallet, Drive, and YouTube.
So now we get
the latest and greatest
Google specific APIs
every six weeks or so.
And rather than being
tied to a specific platform,
they're available on every device,
back to Gingerbread.
Oh, and of course every native app
is also entirely replaceable.
So you can publish apps
to replace any of the apps
shipped with the device.
And we can build our own SMS apps,
homescreens or maps apps,
publish it on Play and give users
the choice to make it their default.
When Android
was first announced,
Andy Rubin described the AOSP as,
all the software to run a mobile phone
but without the proprietary obstacles
that have hindered mobile innovation.
Today, Android runs on more
than just mobiles,
but the core of its purpose
remains the same.
A platform and ecosystem
that allows models, carriers,
OEMs and app developers
to innovate and compete.
So armed with an open,
evolving platform
enriched by a growing
set of Google API's
and the ability to create
great apps that let users
customize every aspect
of their user experience,
you can use other people's work
to help define the computing platform
of the future.
And that's my definition of open.